[Music]
you might be eating these things
everyday but you will quickly change
your habits once you know that you're
eating maggots rubber chemical
ingredients and more just wait until you
see which McDonald's meal looked the
same after 14 years in a coat pocket
you'll never eat that again if this is
your first time watching our Channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 foods you'll never
buy again knowing how they are made
hotdogs have you ever looked at a
sausage and wondered how this weird
thing came from an animal it's already
disgusting to think that we are actually
eating a corpse but we will get over it
however you might not be ready to see
how a beautiful pig is turned into a
weird-looking sausage step by step as
you know you first have to end the life
of the pig which is never an easy thing
to do then it all starts with what's
left of the beef and pork after butchers
took the best parts of these animals
they are fed into a machine it passes
through grated metal plates and
processed chicken trimmings are added to
the mix this is when we get the most
disgusting part the meat mixture is
blended until it is liquefied and it
turns into something that we will never
want to see again this is how they can
add food starch salt brown mustard and
other flavorings water is blended into
the mix and everything is blended
together to make sure that it looks even
more disgusting the meat puree is then
pumped into the casings and ready to go
in a smoker to get the additional
flavorings we don't know about you but
we think we'll eat a hamburger instead
but just wait until you see how this
other meal is made
hey guys please check out the most
awesome sisters on YouTube sister fun
watch can play the latest games go on
amazing adventures and just doing all
sorts of fun and silly things if you
have kids little brothers or sisters or
if you just want to join in on the
family fun please subscribe to their
Channel
chewing gum you have all heard your
parents tell you that you shouldn't
swallow your chewing gum because it will
be stuck in your belly for seven years
some of you probably still believe it at
least if we have one good thing to tell
you is that it will just take a few days
for your chewing gum to end up in the
toilet but unfortunately there is a good
reason why your parents told you that
you shouldn't eat chewing gum that's
because this delicious candy is actually
made of something that we shouldn't put
in our mouth it all starts with the gum
base which makes the chewing gum chewy
it used to be made from tree resin but
it's now synthetic you'll want to eat
resin again once you learn that your
favorite candy is actually made of
plastics and rubbers the gum base is
poured into a mixer and this is when
they can add color flavoring and
sweetener these are probably the only
things that we can eat in a chewing gum
and this is the reason why this sweet
only lasts a couple of minutes before
there is nothing left to taste at least
now we understand why we shouldn't
swallow chewing them tell this to the
kids instead of scaring them with this
crazy myth blue cheese have you ever
wondered why this cheese is blue you
won't believe that this color is
actually caused by mold you would think
that it's not good to eat anymore but
this is actually what people love about
it we are not sure that we agree with
them but if you do you can even make
your own blue cheese at home start with
a normal cheese recipe and make it
disgusting as soon as it comes out of
the press create air holes by inserting
a ride in the cheese at every inch or so
then rub the surface with salt and fold
a cloth over it to cover the cheese put
it in the refrigerator with good air
ventilation and wait 10 days you might
think that your cheese is not good
anymore but if you see a white bloom on
the surface that's a good sign then you
can wait another two months or more and
see the result now we understand why
this cheese smells so bad but don't
worry it's still good to eat if you ever
dare go near it mold is usually
dangerous because it affects our
respiratory system and can even cause
carcinogens but in the cheese there are
no toxins which makes the mold good to
eat we don't know who had that weird
idea and we're not sure we want to know
more about this yogurt it's time to eat
something healthy you might be wondering
how can it go wrong but you might be
surprised know that yogurt is actually
full of bacterias and that's not even a
mistake it is just made like that we
have been making yogurt in the same ways
for centuries even though things are now
easier with machines the first thing you
need to do is separate the milk into
skim and cream it's also thickens with a
gelatin or milk powder if you are a
vegetarian and don't know what gelatin
is made up you'll have to keep watching
this video they then heat the thick milk
to kill off any harmful bacteria through
pasteurization so don't worry the food
is actually safe to eat but wait until
you see what is coming next the most
important thing to make the yogurt
tastes like yogurt is to pour good
bacteria into the mix you heard that
right is actually part of the main
ingredients the amount and type vary
from one company to another but it's
still disgusting to think that we are
eating this and we didn't even know
about this the bacteria work together to
metabolize the lactose to form new
chemicals the fermentation then lasts
for three or four hours until the yogurt
is thick and creamy is it us or we just
don't want to eat anything anymore now
bacon how can something so good be so
bad any bacon lover doesn't want to
watch this but you know that you won't
be able to resist the temptation to keep
watching this video traditionally bacon
is made by rubbing a cut of pork belly
with a mixture of salt and spice before
leaving the meat for a week we would
have no problems eating that unless we
were vegan but mass production turned
our favorite meal of the day into
something disgusting that's because the
meat received injections of salty water
which can also include chemicals like
absorb ik acid potassium nitrate and
sodium nitrate don't think that they are
making the food better for you when they
do this the main reason why they add
this to the meat is to make the bacon
heavier when you are buying bacon in the
supermarket you were actually buy an
expensive water the meat is then cooked
and placed into a cooler for a couple of
days until it's ready to slice at least
you'll be happy to hear that the meat
does go through a metal detector to make
sure the pieces of the metal hanger are
not left in the bacon does that mean
that it happened before it will let our
siblings eat all the bacon that we have
for breakfast this time the fruits
suddenly taste better gummy bear
remember when we told you that
vegetarians wouldn't be happy to hear
how gelatin is made now it's time to
tell you the truth about the ingredient
that you can find in your favorite
candies including the gummy bears most
gummies are made from gelatin which is
made from animal skin and bones they use
what is left of the dead bodies of the
animals to create the gummies that we
all love there are tons of body parts
and when you look at this mountain of
animal corpses you can't help but feel
sorry for those pigs who suffer only so
we can eat a tiny candy the meat is
turned into little strings which are
then turned into something that looks
like a powder it's turned into a liquid
and this is when they add color and
flavor then out of a machine comes a
delicious little treat that we'd love to
taste at least this is what we thought
before we saw those pictures we might
feel a little less guilty when we eat a
steak but killing animals to make
something that we don't really need
doesn't seem right at least companies
are starting to make vegan gummies for
the best of everyone if you're
vegetarian were you surprised to know
that gummies are made from animals don't
be shy to share your thoughts in the
comment section down below breakfast
sandwiches going to a fast food
restaurant is the best way to start the
morning you don't have to cook and you
have a delicious meal anyway which is
way better than a simple bowl of cereal
you might feel a little heavier during
the rest of the day but it won't stop
you from doing the same thing the next
morning and the reason why you might
feel bad is probably that it contains
things that you would never put in your
mouth if you knew what it was you can
probably find the worst breakfast
sandwich at Subway
one of the ingredients is propylene
glycol it's a solvent for food colors
and flavorings that is also used in
antifreeze and deodorant sticks and to
lubricate air conditioner compressors
then we have glycerine a solvent that we
can find in soaps moisturizers and some
brands of shaving cream we also have
TBHQ or tertiary butyl hydroquinone
which is used to preserve vegetable oils
against oxidation it doesn't sound that
bad unless you know that it's also used
in perfumes lacquers and varnishes and
you can forget dimethyl poli-sci alloxan
which can be found in silly putty and
mini lubricants and there's also calcium
silicates a sealant used on roofs roads
and concrete we'll just skip the most
important meal of the day instead that's
not worth it french fries what could go
wrong with french fries it's just
potatoes cover with a tomato sauce that
we call ketchup but McDonald's found a
way to make those french fries
disgusting mostly for vegetarians it
actually takes 19 ingredients to
transform a potato into a piece of gold
we would expect to see things like
potatoes different oils and salt but we
don't really like to hear that we can
also find citric acid dimethyl poli-sci
alloxan dextrose sodium acid
pyrophosphate and TBHQ if you can't
pronounce it you shouldn't put it in
your mouth but all these weird
ingredients were not the reason why
people were shocked what they hated the
most was the natural beef flavor
McDonald's fries are a pre cooked in
beef tallow which is described as
natural flavoring Hindus who don't eat
beef for religious reasons and
vegetarians were not happy to hear about
that this is why in June 2002 McDonald's
was forced to pay ten million dollars to
Hindu and vegetarian groups who thought
that the fries were vegan but there's
also one last thing that anyone will
hate about french fries from McDonald's
after four years in a sealed jar they
looks the same when we look at the KFC
fries we know that this is not normal
but just wait until you see which thing
from McDonald's stayed the same for 14
years tomato sauce here's another thing
that we're going to ruin you will never
look at your pasta covered with tomato
sauce the same way again this time we
don't really care about how they are
made but about what we can find in the
ingredients at least that was in plans
but that doesn't stop it from being
there you'll want to keep watching if
you're vegan because you might
accidentally find something that is
alive on your plates if you go to an
Italian restaurant and you will be even
less happy to hear that you won't find
animals but bugs in the tomato sauce
that's because the FDA doesn't care if
there are flies or maggots in your
tomato sauce according to the US Food
and Drug Administration it's totally
normal to find 30 or more fly eggs per
100 grams you could even find one maggot
per 100 grams the numbers are similar
for canned tomatoes tomato juice tomato
puree and pasta pizza sauce and other
sauces sometimes they can even tolerate
30 fly eggs or 2 maggots per 100
milligrams that's something we wish we
never knew about now that we think about
all the tomatoes that we ate recently
anyway you probably won't notice the fly
eggs in your plate let's just say that
maggots are full of protein hamburgers
now that you watch this video you won't
be able to eat anything and if you
thought that you wouldn't be able to
stop yourself from eating a hamburger at
McDonalds anyway will make you change
your mind people start by inspecting
cuts of meat before they are sent
through the grinder it is formed into
beef patties and sent into a giant
freezer just before they are boxed and
packaged for shipping some patties are
even tested before the batches of meat
are sent out the fast-food restaurant
also had to explain that they don't use
pink slime in this recipe to make people
feel less disgusted all this sounds
normal which is why it's weird to think
that a hamburger could be so disgusting
but you won't be happy to hear that this
is the thing that stayed the same after
14 years in a coat pocket a scientists
even conducted a series of tests to
understand if burgers would rot over
time and he thought that because of the
burgers small size and large surface
area it would lose moisture very fast
without moisture bacterias or mold can't
grow we don't know about you but we are
not going to McDonald's anytime soon is
there any disgusting food that you would
love to eat anyway don't be shy to tell
us what it is in the comment section
down below we'd love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 foods you'll
never buy again knowing how they're made
for more stories like this make sure you
watch the second part of 10 foods you'll
never buy again after knowing how
they're made thanks for watching
[Music]